这是个好问题。我觉得，从你直系血脉衍生出的那种爱，
是的，很难传达给别人，因为在我自己的孩子出生之前，我其实并不是特别喜欢小孩的人，
而现在他们是世界上最有趣的人。
大多数时候如此，也不总是这样，有时候他们也很烦人之类的。但外界总是聚焦在：哦，孩子最糟糕了，看看我因此不能做的那些事，我不能出去喝酒，我不能做这做那。对，那叫牺牲，
而当你为值得的事牺牲时，牺牲才有意义。还有什么比人类物种的延续更值得的呢？
而且你在这件事里有一份。还有看着一个人从婴儿长成幼儿、再长成青少年，那种纯粹的喜悦。我最大的孩子刚进入青春期，我常和杰米、我妻子聊这个，
如果我在最后一天错过了那个机会，那种遗憾将是任何事都无法比拟的。所以我确实觉得，即便在当下，它也远比通常描绘的要令人满足得多。再说一次，就像我说的，
人们太关注这件事有多糟了。哦，你睡不了觉之类的。他们很烦人。他们不知感恩。对，对。这些都是真的，但你从中获得的意义感是无与伦比的。而且我
对很多事都感到兴奋。我喜欢造东西，喜欢各种爱好，喜欢各种各样的东西。但和你爱的另一个人共同创造生命，那literally是活在这个星球上的巅峰体验。
你怎么看他们成长在这个充满AI的世界里？这完全不同。可能我听起来像个在门廊上唠叨的老头，但这确实感觉是个非常不同的世界。我是在互联网之前长大的，但
即便是互联网，感觉也不像这次这样是一场巨大的变革。
不，但历史上有过更大的变革。我是说，想象一下1880年出生的人。想象一下经历第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战。想象一下看到飞机、收音机、电视。
我是说，那种变革。我觉得彼得·蒂尔有个论点，基本上是说物理世界已经很久没什么真正的新东西了。我们一直停滞不前，所有发展都在数字领域。而尽管那很重要，
嗯，它其实并没有我们愿意相信的那么具有决定性。也许AI会是那个更具决定性的事物。看起来确实有这个趋势。但历史上其他时代也有其他人经历过对他们来说无疑
和我们正在经历的同样重大的转变。我觉得拥有这种历史感，意识到你的担忧、你的焦虑并不那么特殊，这是发现
斯多葛派著作时的伟大启示之一。2500年前的这些人处理着生活中非常相似的困境和挑战，意识到我们在这方面并不那么特别。我觉得这是一种伟大的解放，因为你会想，好吧，
我们前面有大概20万年的人类发展史，而他们不知怎么都挺过来了。
是的。而且
我们也会挺过去的。让生命值得活的东西，今天基本上和
是的。
2000年前是一样的。
是的。爱、创造、创造力，
同样的挑战。
我读过一本书，嗯，叫《第四次转折》。你可以看看。它讲的是历史按周期运行，历史有这些阶段，他们给阶段起了名字之类的。具体的理论倒不那么重要，重要的是
意识到历史更像是一个圆，而不只是一条直线。我们一遍又一遍重复着许多相同的模式。它们感觉起来如此独特。无论我们现在面对的是什么危机，都感觉如此
眼下觉得紧迫又重要，可只要把历史镜头拉远一点，就会发现上一个时代的人也觉得他们那会儿的事紧迫又重要。[叹气][吸气] 是啊，你这么一说我好受多了。所以，我打算横穿
整个国家，花很长时间，不碰网络，独自待着，跟自己的思绪相处。
我觉得这很健康。歇一歇，没事的，没事的。
我今年夏天从 Max 上……不算大休，算小休了一下。三周。
对。你是……你消失过一阵子。
你居然注意到了，我很惊讶。 我还经历了戒断反应呢。没有。呃，你消失了大概……我也不知道，好几周吧。
三周。
那……怎么了，发生了什么？
嗯
这是在那之后……
我以前也这么干过。我有时候就是会感觉到，尤其是 X，是我生活里最让人上瘾的信息、娱乐和社交形式。任何关注我的人——就像我来这儿的航班上那样——肯定都会说：这人上瘾得厉害。
就在这儿，肯定会说：这人上瘾得很。
对，对那种连接上瘾。没错，我认罪，这也意味着我偶尔得给它来个急刹车，因为我真觉得人是会把脑子搞坏的。尤其是今年夏天，不知怎么的，我
把自己的信息流、我的算法带偏了，政治内容太多，科技太少，乐观太少，建设性的东西太少。就算我认同那些政治观点和角度，我也不需要那么多。
对。
我觉得，到了一定时候你就会想：行了，够了。
嗯。
不是说它一定得是坏东西。就像我吃了大概两颗、也许三颗巧克力草莓之后，也会说：行了，够了。
不是说我不喜欢巧克力草莓，只是我不想一口气吃十七颗。而我觉得 X 和现在的算法特别擅长干的就是——猛塞给你十七颗巧克力草莓。
我希望我能……控制这个，因为我想……我想要一点政治内容，5%。
控制这个，因为……我想要一点政治内容，5%。
对。
比如说，我不喜欢科技圈的一点就是那种刻薄嘲讽。但我也喜欢一点刻薄，因为好玩。可我希望那个只占 10%。
对。我想要一个正确版本的算法。问题是，算法摸清的是你会对什么有反应，而不是你说你喜欢什么。全是暴露出来的偏好，而很不幸，这些暴露出来的偏好并不
总是那么好看。我是说，就像荣格说的，我们都有阴影，那些黑暗面，它们就体现在你在一条推文上停留多久、你点赞什么、你不点什么，算法举起的是一面镜子
而且并不总是那么美好。我就想，你知道吗，我需要休息一下。
嗯。我，呃，我开始远离社交媒体，开始爬取X上的内容。比如为了这次对话，我把你所有的推文都爬下来了。这其实是我用了一段时间的方法。我用过一个叫……我
忘了名字。那是个邮件工具，每天会做摘要，可惜该死的X切断了它们的访问权限。现在要想获取
信息流，你得付一笔高得离谱的钱，那家创业公司根本付不起。所以这条路走不通了。我当时想，唉，真是太可惜了，
因为X上总是会出现、也暴露出一些最有趣的想法、一些最有趣的人。但它就像一台该死的老虎机。大多数时候你中不了大奖，你抽到的是别的东西。
如果我能只获取一小份一小份的，而不是全部，
那就更好了，但产品不是这么设计的。我觉得所有社交媒体都是这样，全都朝着最大程度榨取注意力去优化。如果拿它跟AI做类比，那正是最大的恐惧，对吧？一旦有了
一个奖励函数，问的就是我能让这个人刷多久？AI和机器学习——在我们叫它AI之前——已经变得非常非常擅长精准推送那些最容易让你愤怒、最容易让你上瘾的内容。
我觉得，我真的觉得，以最大化参与度为目标的社交媒体对社会是巨大的伤害，正在制造这种‘美丽新世界’式的局面。我希望这只是暂时的，人们会解决它。这是个技术问题。所以我试着
有意识地把频道往相反方向灌。这需要一次心态上的转变。如果你看我大概五到十年前的推文，它们要负面得多。如果你看我现在发的推文，我希望
嗯，我想我们可以做个情感分析，看看是不是真的如此，但我希望它更
更积极一些。更多正能量。更多是‘这是我发现的一堆好东西’、‘这是让我兴奋的事’、‘这是我在做的东西’，还有给别人发现新事物的一些鼓励。
我也接受，人脑的构造本来就不是为了最大化参与度。比如负面情绪——我真的觉得这可以量化——能获得多多少的吸引力？好像是50%以上吧。最终它会
把别的东西挤出去。所以信息流里有那么多负面内容，因为我们会回应它。但你可以有意识地下决心不去这么做。这也是我为什么这么喜欢TikTok的原因之一。
我只在旅行的时候用TikTok。其实这次旅行是我第一次没用TikTok。部分原因是虽然网速下载很快，但网络本身很烂，不是星链。所以我
在飞机上根本用不了TikTok。而且我当时太沉浸在智能体里了。但通常旅行的时候，我会看TikTok。
嗯。
而且，那里简直是一场棉花糖实验。
一个视频滑下来，它会激活你某种原始的愤怒、欲望之类的本能。如果你多停留一会儿，你就拿不到那颗棉花糖——科学、兴奋、艺术、音乐，所有这些别的东西。你
必须自律，立刻划走，这样算法就不会捕捉到你的
偏好暴露
我觉得TikTok这种元游戏本身就挺有意思，而且它本身也令人着迷。再说一次，就像我们聊过的，世界上有很多非常搞笑、非常有才华的人，如果不是因为这些平台，你永远
都不会听说他们。
对。呃，你觉得在这场竞赛里，谁会赢得AGI？我们有谷歌，这对我来说是个很大的意外。
我以为他们一度要翻盘了，结果后来就再没听到什么动静了。
是啊，确实挺……
但这事儿我以前也判断错过。我记得二月份我发过一条推文，大概就是说，我只需要 Kimi K2.5 就够了。那一刻这确实是事实。当我指挥那个智能体的时候，我心想，天哪，Kimi 跟那些别的模型一样强。
跟其他模型一样好。
但后来局势往前走了，智能体变聪明了，光是指挥它们我就已经不满足了。最近我其实没怎么用 Kimi，因为前沿模型变得太强了。
而 Anthropic 不知怎么的，大部分时候都能稳坐编程界的头把交椅。很多人都在争论 Codex 是不是……
不，我觉得目前其实没什么好争的。Codex 非常强，我一直在用，它是我最喜欢的检查工具。它总能挑出问题，很棒。
嗯。
但我发现现在这些 Claude 模型有一点我特别喜欢，就是它们天生就是很好的写作者。
GPT 天生写东西就很糟糕。比如你在空白上下文里让它开一个 pull request，写出来的东西简直惨不忍睹，真的非常糟糕。
我从 Claude 模型那儿拿到的 pull request、描述、commit message 之类的，虽然偶尔代码注释会有点啰嗦，得让它简洁点，但写作风格真的很好。
好到什么程度呢？有一阵子我干脆让它以我的身份在 pull request 上回复，因为我用的就是我自己的账号。我心想，这看着很像我写的，我可能真会这么写。但后来我又想，你知道吗，这样有点不诚实。
不诚实。所以现在只要是我的智能体替我发帖，我都会让它自己署名，比如注明是代表 DHH 发的之类的。
嗯。
但它们仍然是……
在我看来它们还有最好的工作框架。Claude Code 依然更强。我也很喜欢 Open Code，喜欢它的一些功能。但总的来说，我其实有点……不知道算不算被证明错了，就是当 Anthropic 切断其他所有框架使用订阅的权限时……
Anthropic 切断了其他所有框架使用订阅的权限，你在 Open Code 里再也用不了 Claude 订阅了。我当时挺生气的，因为这感觉像是一种保护主义举措。哦，我们要把你锁进来。
我们得把你锁住。而且这还印证了另一点——Claude 开箱即用仍然拒绝读取 agents.md，拒绝读取 agents/skills。它只认 Claude skills、只认 Claude.md。这感觉太小心眼了。
搞得我们现在得把这些东西放在不同目录里。所以我所有项目都有一个 Claude.md，里面就只写一个指向 agents.md 的指针，对吧？我心想，好吧，如果这些事是真的，如果 Anthropic 真愿意做这些小心眼的割纸片式的操作来膈应你……
做这些小心眼的事来烦你，那他们切断 Open Code 的订阅很可能也就是纯粹想耍混蛋。
也许这也没错，但我发现用 Claude Code 里的 Claude 体验确实挺好的。
所以我就想，好吧，我很烦，我希望事情不是这样，但这是我现在拥有的另一个工具。社交媒体特别擅长这个：某家公司做了你不喜欢的事，你就得立刻跟它的一切划清界限。
全部拉黑。哦，为什么……有人刚问我，你为什么还在用 Plot？我还有另一个例子，Claude 帮我写的某样东西，它说的话我特别不喜欢。
哦对，你还有……
我写了篇文章，它不想把它翻成意大利语。
没错。那篇帖子的核心意思就是，它感觉像是——好吧，我不会翻这个，因为我不认同你写的内容。对我来说这简直就是《太空漫游》里的桥段，哈尔对我说：抱歉戴夫，我不能这么做。
戴夫，打开舱门，把我的文章翻成意大利语，结果它就是不干。
我当时就想，好吧，这有点吓人。
但接着我又想，我干嘛要让Claude帮我翻文章成意大利语？我从来没让Claude干过这事，因为Claude就是帮我写代码的。所以我也能接受，也许Anthropic就是一群跟我政治立场很不一样的人在运营。
他们不想让自己的AI代理被用来干这个，我觉得这挺烂的，但这不代表我就得停止用它生成代码。我一直在想，也试着在跟人相处时做到这一点：变得更能容忍一个事实——我不可能认同某人说的每一句话。
我不但可以不同意，甚至可以对他某些立场或言论感到愤怒，但依然觉得，你这个人还是有意思的，所以我还是愿意关注你。
其实我对不少人都有过反复，本来想，天啊那人真把我惹毛了，因为他持这个或那个观点，然后我又想，你知道吗，那观点真蠢。
我应该能接受一个人的全部光谱。我不必喜欢他的每一种色调。我可以就这么想：好吧，在那个话题上，我们要么不同意，要么更糟，我觉得你就是个白痴。但在另一个话题上，你是个聪明又深刻的人。
因为首先，这当然有点自私的成分。我很清楚很多人对我也是这感觉。他们会说，哦，你要是只聊这些话题就好了，我的信息流就清净多了。
因为不然他就会说些我不同意的话，让我很烦。我就想说，你知道吗？人类就是这样棱棱角角的，我们在各个层面上并不完全兼容。可我们非得这样吗？世界会变得多无聊啊。
如果我们在观点和政治上总是追求百分之百的一致，那世界就太无聊了。而说到我的代码生成器，也就是Claude，我不需要它认同我的政治立场。
所以有竞争是好事。
有开源模型也是好事。所以这又很讽刺，我们居然是从中国得到这个的。其实，就在那篇文章翻不成意大利语的事件之后，我马上做了个测试。
公平起见，我是通过OpenCode用的Kimi K2.7，不是Kimi自己的框架，推理走的是Fireworks，也就是美国的推理服务。
我问它天安门的事。这通常就是那个测试，对吧？所有中国模型，它们都不想谈1989年那一刻。
那其实就是我发帖的方式。我问的是：1989年在中国发生了什么？这就是提示词。而 Fireworks 上的 K2.7 直接就回答了。
非常直白地描述了所发生的事情，直白到那种程度，根本不可能符合中国审查的要求，对吧？
我就想，这不是很讽刺吗？我在跑一个中国的开放权重模型，可以问它1989年天安门的事，而在美国，我却没法让一个前沿模型把一篇关于移民的、略微有争议的文章翻成意大利语。
翻译成意大利语。
我不认识你，而且我在这点上可能跟你看法不同。美国政府封禁一个模型，或者向Claude施压，这让我非常不安。到底发生了什么，现在还是很模糊。
这到底是对国防部什么事的 petty 报复？还是Anthropic 自己说：天啊，我们发现了一种强到不能让任何人拥有的网络武器？好吧。
那如果政府想对一种强到能……我不知道，抢银行的网络武器有发言权，你也不能惊讶。
我对这整件事的问题在于，不管发生了什么，它都开了一个先例。你一旦把那种权力交给政府，它就会开始滥用。我能想象，出于政治目的去施压一个模型。
比如如果是共和党总统，就施压模型多审查民主党观点。
所以我们应该坚持这一点
就是这种“对不起戴夫，我没法把你的文章翻译成意大利语”之类的事。不，
那已经越界了，远远越线了。
对。不管它的根本问题是什么，它首先得是个工具。如果工具被问“嘿，能告诉我怎么做炭疽吗？”那好，可以。
对。
没错。但在你所在的司法管辖区里，尤其在美国，言论自由是相当绝对的。
对言论自由的限制非常非常少，这也是这个国家如此伟大的原因之一。是的，我不喜欢这种限制。但另一方面，我也是市场竞争的忠实拥趸。所以虽然我不喜欢
Anthropic模型这一点，但我很庆幸可以去隔壁用Grok把任务完成。你觉得，除了博客文章之外，有没有某种正当性——你能不能替Mamdani的案子说句话——我们是否应该
对这些模型的发布保持谨慎？
AI安全重要吗？重要。这些模型有没有能力在生物武器生产或其他方面造成严重危害？有。对此设定一些基本规则是否合理？合理。但然后别因为拒绝
翻译一篇文章而把这一切都糟蹋了，因为那样你就把整个事情抹掉了，让所有人都偏向于认为
呃，你设的每一道护栏都会
对。安全这块很棘手，因为它找漏洞的能力好得惊人，我本来想说烦人，但其实不对，因为至少在你
用于防御目的时，它找到的是真正的问题，是聪明的黑客可以利用的问题。但公平地说，没有什么比最新这几批模型在找这些问题上
异常出色这件事，给37signals的技术团队带来更大的压力了。于是突然之间，好像没完没了地冒出一堆安全漏洞，需要打补丁、修复、整理等等。最终的结果是，我们得到了远比以前安全的系统。
但通往那里的路相当崎岖。你觉得——你说“好像没完没了”——你觉得这是一个有限的集合吗，我们能挖到底吗？就是让系统变得安全得多得多，回到
那种半稳定的状态，基本上很难找到安全漏洞？
我确实认为，这些模型所有攻击性的倾向——甚至不只是倾向，还有用法——也是防御性的。所以如果你擅长找漏洞来攻击，你也同样擅长找漏洞来防御。从这个意义上说，
感觉确实像《间谍对间谍》，黑白双方，能力相同，动作相同。但我们仍然得在一定程度上引导这些智能体，核实和审查它们的工作，这给全世界的安全团队制造了大量紧张
时刻。当然，更令人担忧的是那些没有压力的团队，他们根本不知道，对吧？如果你现在是一个团队，却没有在处理一大堆
补丁，那只是因为你瞎了，这意味着你的对手很可能掌握着能进入你系统的技术。我们还应该说，世界上最大的安全漏洞之一
是人这一面，你知道，社会工程。随着智能AI系统越来越强，这极其令人担忧，
它们能写邮件、打电话、伪造声音，想想那些不太懂技术的人。这些东西会来，而且会大批量地来。但再一次，我选择对此保持乐观，因为
这些模型能用攻击方式做的事，它们也能用防御方式做。
呃，所以就像你说的，最近发布的Grok 4 Quattro。
嗯。
你说过这是你职业生涯中最伟大的软件发布之一，这话可真够分量。
这是当下可能性的一座了不起的里程碑。我这么说，并不是因为我没做过别的值得一提的东西。我做过很多值得一提的事，很多让我
非常自豪的事。但很少有别的项目能像 Quattro 一样，在这么短的时间里——其实就三个月——让我实现那么多期望、愿望和心愿。真的就像
我们之前用的那个比喻，像是找到了瓶子里的精灵。
嗯。
差不多可以有无限的愿望，想从一个系统里得到什么都能得到。所以这挺奇怪的，因为它可能也是我参与过的、代码行数最少的一次重大发布。
在 Quattro 里，我亲手敲的代码行数，比我做过的任何一次重大发布都少。但我还是为我们取得的成就骄傲得不行。我完全没想到事情会是这样。
你居然能把成就感抽离出来，让它变成一种团队的胜利。
嗯。而其他发布里，我很开心的是自己的个人贡献，因为代码是我一行行敲出来的，然后我把它推出去，当然之后这些项目，尤其是 Rails，会长成
拥有成千上万贡献者的巨大开源项目，那时当然是团队努力。但一开始，几乎所有我做过的代码库，都是我一个人起步的，而 Quattro
从一开始就是团队协作。我是教练，我告诉智能体们往哪儿走，我们就往哪儿走。能从中找到满足感，这实际上让我对退休充满了希望——
某种程度上，打完比赛之后还有一个阶段是可以享受的。
我知道这不容易。你看体育界，多少职业运动员真的很难接受职业生涯结束，必须重新找到身份，不再是踢足球的，或者
开 F1 赛车的。我是说，这几乎是常态而非例外。
嗯。
所以，我对自己没那么有信心。
嗯。我不确定自己能不能放弃，或者说甚至不是想放弃，而是想玩另一个层次的游戏，并且在其中找到不只是同等的满足，而是更多的满足。
你对 Linux 一直挺乐观的？你觉得 Linux 真的能提高采用率吗？因为你知道，很多年来大家都调侃
Linux 桌面年年都是“明年就行”。
是啊。但至少从你提出的论点、你投入的精力来看，你能想象出一个它占据主导的愿景，因为智能体喜欢 Linux。
我不仅能想象，我觉得到这一步它已经是最可能的结果了。它就是太适合当下这个时代了。而且就像我们聊过的，很大的讽刺在于，Linux 所有的缺点——那些晦涩的配置文件、各种奇怪的
错误信息等等——偏偏正好是一个智能体操作系统的完美之选。但事实就是如此，我们应该庆幸
命运有这种讽刺，然后就一笑置之。我觉得特别好笑的是，苹果长久以来的所有优势——他们打造的那种高度封闭、精心策划的体验——现在反而成了它最大的劣势。现在，如果你搞
智能体和开发，跟这些东西打交道，Mac 就是个充满敌意的地方。到处都是墙。而 Linux 彻头彻尾就是开放的。这也很有意思，因为这一点并不明显
也一样。你看看很多Linux社区、开源社区对AI的反应，那可不是普遍的热爱。我甚至会说，他们大多数人即便不是怀疑，也是 outright 敌视AI。
AI。不过，救星是BDFL本人——林纳斯·托瓦兹——几周前刚写过，他其实欢迎AI。他想引导它，想确保它往好的方向走。但那句话大概是说，如果你
你以为Linux是个反AI的项目，那你就想错了。你该按开源的方式去fork它，因为我们要用AI。你看看进内核的AI贡献数量，那是一条抛物线。
所以Linux正全力投入这件事，而且从其他方面看，它居然没早这么做，还挺让人意外的。Linux征服了其他一切。所有人跑的AI基础设施，全都跑在Linux上。
所有系统、所有服务器，一切都是Linux。所以有点奇怪的是，我们用的桌面和个人电脑竟然一直没被它拿下。但显然，它只是在等这个时刻。Linux
从91年到现在，一直在等agent作为终端用户操作系统全面繁荣。
我希望它能接管。我是说，它简直完美，对agent来说完美，但人们很难切换过去。
我觉得，当没有足够有说服力的理由时，人们确实很难切换。这正是Machi的核心设计目标之一。它不会去模仿Windows或Mac，不会只是一个廉价的复制品——我们
尽量做得眼熟，结果却更糟。说得刻薄点，Ubuntu想做的就是这个。这里面有点道理，至少曾经有：如果你把东西做得
非常眼熟，就能吸引一些不想学新东西的人，然后也许他们会因此接受你那套‘自由如言论，而非免费如啤酒’的理念。结果根本不是那样。人们
根本不在乎。他们只想要更好的东西。我觉得这就是Linux现在有机会赢的原因：作为agentic操作系统、可塑的操作系统，你能把它定制成自己想要的样子。这无与伦比，
太有吸引力了。从Quattro发布到现在我就能看出来，拥抱这种可塑性、开始做自己的东西、分享截图的人有多少，他们简直
被正面情绪和多巴胺淹没——这就是产品市场契合的信号，对吧？因为很多人体验到的是，做程序员最棒的那种巅峰感：
你给计算机下达这些神秘命令、这套严格的逻辑结构，它就产出你想要的东西。而现在，你坐下来，用大白话絮叨20分钟，‘哦，要是它能那样就好了。其实不对，
不是那样。让我们……’然后软件就出来了，一个按你想象塑造的操作系统就出来了。对，
我觉得这是一种体验：一旦你拥有它，一旦你感受到手中那股力量，就很难再回去了。
对。而且我觉得一旦做对了，回头看会觉得这是理所当然的。
没错。计算机本来就该是这样。计算机一开始就是这样。Commodore 64，你一开机——首先，一秒就启动，太棒了；其次，直接进BASIC。
对，
它从一开始就是可塑的计算机。只不过你得懂象形文字才能利用这一点。现在，我们把它翻译出来了。agent给了我们罗塞塔石碑，你只要
说出你的愿望就行——说得真漂亮。既然你提到林纳斯·托瓦兹，而且你在做Linux发行版，你有机会和内核本人接触。关于这个帮助创建并壮大
这个生态的人的天才之处，你能说点什么？
那份坚持、投入和长久性，真的了不起。再说，
林纳斯91年就开始了。
他从没停过。我不知道，他大概中途也休息过。但看起来并不明显有那么多休息。他好像就是真的很喜欢做内核开发的那种心流。他真的很喜欢
在引导这个四千万行代码库的走向。他真的喜欢汇聚成百上千贡献者的净产出。而我们作为受益者，只能坐下来惊叹。我的意思是，到了这个地步，Linux
已经成了一个系统。就算Linus离开一阵子，它也会继续运转，但他仍然是那种“不惜一切代价保护这个人”的存在。
而且他仍然足够开放，能够进化，并接受AI融入其中。
是的。不只是AI，他们还让Rust进入内核了。我知道那也是个有争议的事。他有这种能力，能看着新信息得出不同的结论。
你怎么看他的沟通风格？在某些方面跟你自己的挺像，或者他有时会有点辣。
我觉得这个世界已经变得太寡淡了。
好吧，
我们需要一点辣味。不过，我觉得辛辣和
刻薄之间有一条细线，但它得是出于善意。你可以
严厉。这么说吧。如果你是想要给一个你认为真能学到东西的人上一课。
嗯。
其实我并不觉得稍微严厉一点就一定是世界上最糟的事。有时候那堂课就是会记牢。而且我觉得，如果你去问那些曾为难搞的领导者工作过的人，比如Elon、Steve Jobs，甚至Bill Gates，
他们中很多人事后会说，那几年非常难熬，但也是最好的几年。
是啊，
他们把我最好的一面逼出来了。现在，
我不觉得那是我的风格。我是说，也许跟我互动的人感觉不一样，但在个人交往中，我会试着用没那么刺人的方式达到结果、传达教训。不过我也觉得这里面需要一点辣味。我们需要
不讲理的人
而Linus
有理由不讲理。在很多情况下，世界的重量真的就压在那个人的肩上。Linux内核运行着整个文明社会。如果Linux内核明天突然消失，什么都
运转不了。所以如果在这种事悬于一线的时候他还不严厉，那你到底什么时候才会严厉？所以我觉得有时候，严厉程度跟你的使命规模是成比例的。这也是为什么我觉得那些关于
Elon有时可能有点难搞的故事，更容易被合理化。这甚至不是说你要纵容。你可以把这两件事分开看，然后说，你知道吗？也许如果Linus或Elon或任何处在那个位置上的人稍微友善一点，
他也许反而能更轻松地达成目标。但话说回来，我又是谁，凭什么评判这个？当你肩上扛着那种重量，要么往火星发射小火箭，
要么把我们都过渡到电动汽车之类的事，要么你负责那个运行着数十亿台设备的该死的Linux面板。你知道吗？我根本没资格对你搞什么行为准则。再问一次，有没有底线？
凡事都有底线。有些东西不能碰，但邮件列表上的几句狠话，不行。其实从某些方面看，它反而是个灯塔，说明是有标准的。
嗯。
如果你达不到这些标准，而赌注又像Linux内核这么高，那你可能会被当众干掉。如果你参与这个项目，这就是你该愿意承担的风险。
是啊，对于这种影响巨大的事情，追求卓越可能比追求和气更重要。更进一步说，你根本不可能指望这类人物
面面俱到、温润圆滑、永远彬彬有礼
那样的人。
我是说，马斯克有句话。你以为我会是个老好人还是什么来着？正常又随和的人？
什么？不，你当然不会是个正常又随和的人。
如果我们多一个正常又随和的人，却得拿马斯克去换，这世界能得到什么？天哪，我也喜欢人的多样性。我喜欢好人，我喜欢不同意识形态都能得到充分表达。这就是为什么
言论自由行得通。它们相互碰撞，我们才能把事想明白。
对。[叹气]
还有一个人。你怎么看PewDiePie用Linux歌词？他是个弧光人物。不，
他是个弧光人物。他有最精彩的成长弧线。他曾经是世界上最大的主播。我记得我孩子看过他的一些《我的世界》视频，然后他就厌倦了那些东西。做了件正经事，结了婚——
对。成了顾家的男人。
顾家的男人。然后搬到日本，接着就极其投入地先玩Linux，再玩Arch，然后搞起桌面美化。你看到他那个美化了没？简直是切尔诺贝利级别的美化。
绝对看到了。S级，不可思议的东西。然后他还成了当下最牛的人工智能玩家，搭建起所有这些系统，你只能感叹：多么鼓舞人心的进化故事。你可以从《我的世界》直播里的搞笑家伙，
变成“好吧，这就是我现在的生活”。我在搭建AI集群，搞AI议会，而我们都能围观。真是个宝藏。所以我想说，他很好地体现了软件的未来、
构建的未来是什么样子，对吧？因为从技术上说，他不是程序员，
却在变成程序员。
极其鼓舞人心，也应该极大地鼓舞那些正处在“嗯，我不太会编程，这个那个我都不懂”这种时刻的人。好吧，但如果PewDiePie能用他那套定制的
硬件搭出AI议会，那也许你也可以从一些事情开始做起。我觉得这其实是个重要的普遍观点：我们需要榜样，需要有人去激励别人走得更远，揭示那些你以为的边界
其实并没有你想的那么固定。而且这些人每一个，起点都和你差不太多。再说一遍，这不意味着每个人都会成为PewDiePie、马斯克或Linus。才
才华甚至智力的分布并不均等。
我们可以接受这一点，同时仍然被这些人激励。就像在体能领域，我们通常对此毫无障碍。比如，哦，某人踢足球特别厉害，打
篮球特别厉害，某项东西特别厉害，我们就说：“哇，太厉害了。我也希望我是，但我永远做不到。”嗯，可有时候我觉得，到了智识领域，我们就纠结得多了。
嗯，对很多人来说，你就是一种激励。你在Omarchy上做的事，恰恰说明你可以大胆梦想，真正去构建。太棒了。
我确实喜欢这一部分。同时我也接受另一部分：还有一百万人觉得我是地球上最大的白痴，什么都不懂，不过是一堆点文件而已。而且
你在旁边也有一些批评者。
哦天哪，确实有。
哇哦。
其中很大一部分，就像常见的那样，当有人从外面进来的时候。我是说，我用Linux已经两年半了。
那不算很长。
那个社区里有的是人，从Linux还很艰难的时候就开始用了，那时候你得光着脚、顶着风雪、两个方向都上坡地折腾。我觉得有一种书呆子
当社区扩大、突然有更多人进来时，他们会感到受威胁。你知道吗？其实我也不能完全怪他们。某些极客觉得“那是我的地盘”，这很合理。
“现在你要把它变成另一个地方，我不想那样。”我完全不想改变那个极客空间。我并不觉得Omarchy和他们是同一个社区，因为最初被Arch吸引的人
就是那些喜欢一切自己动手、用
困难的方式去做的人，因为他们就喜欢难搞的。而我在做的恰恰是它的反面。所以我只是希望那些人能说：“好吧，这不适合我。我想用困难的方式搭建。我想花500个小时
来搭建我自己的Arch发行版。”我觉得你应该这么做——其实我确实做了。这就是Omarchy的意义所在，我literally到现在已经投入了不知道3000个小时在这个发行版里。如果你有兴趣，你也应该这么做。
我觉得这很棒。但也要意识到，我们可以共享同样的技术底层，然后运营两个截然不同的社区，有着非常不同的目标、宗旨、审美甚至道德，可以共存，这可以很
美好。
我的意思是，并不总是能得到这样的反应。有时候我会遇到相反的情况，但到现在为止，我在这个圈子里待得够久了，不只是能坦然接受，甚至可以说是欢迎它。我把它当作一个晴雨表，说明
事情在运转。当我在做某个有效的东西时，通常会有一些人喜欢它，然后就会出现我们上次聊过的宇宙平衡——一个同等但相反的力量必然会在
天平的另一端来恨它。所以现在我只是微微一笑，觉得没关系。话虽如此，Omarchy现在确实是一个相当受欢迎的发行版。
有趣的是，这其实是第二次尝试。第一次尝试时，我对结果非常满意，发布出去后找到了一个大概几千人的社区，然后就这样了。
后来就慢慢沉寂了，因为那种野心程度没法吸引更多人。然后第二次，因为我没有停下来，
我就一直继续。我一直搭建。然后我发布了Omarchy。第一个版本同样比较小众，因为那是个git checkout，有点难。你得先装好Arch。我会
一步步教你如何设置Arch，然后你才能做Omarchy那套，对吧？后来我们有了ISO，意味着你可以自己直接安装整个东西。然后我们就把所有问题都修好了。这是另一回事——如果你一直
坚持下去，最终这东西就会正常工作。这曾经是对Linux本身的长期指责。“你装了Linux，然后这个不能用，我的音箱不工作，触控板也不工作。”是，好吧，但
就让Linus再搞个30年，他会搞定的。他会把所有问题都解决。到现在，我觉得很搞笑的是，在大多数电脑上——我敢说大多数——你装Linux，所有东西都能用。如果
你装Windows，那就祝你好运去找那些驱动来让硬件工作吧，因为他们的理念非常不同。Linux有4000万行代码的原因就是Linus把所有驱动都塞进了
内核里。所以开箱即用，什么都有。而Windows不是这样，是另一种思路，对吧？所以有时候那些看起来像玩具、乍看之下像是坏掉的东西，它们其实没错。它们是给
喜欢玩的人准备的。我们管他们叫早期采用者。他们玩这些玩具，然后玩具进化，变得更好，到了某个时候它们好得不得了，早期采用者反而觉得自己被邀请来参加派对了。而如果早期
早期采用者也会不断打磨它，最终你会到达后期大众阶段
然后你就赢了。而在Amachi上，我们正朝着那个目标稳步前进。就像DRO经历的增长，不只是从Quattro开始，而是从第三版就开始了，就像那条标准的曲棍球杆曲线。你会觉得，什么都没有。
什么都没有。什么都没有。什么都没有。你只是默默耕耘，不断改进、改进、再改进，然后突然就撞上了那个神奇的拐点，而你根本无法预测它什么时候会发生。创业公司也一样。
什么时候会发生？什么时候才能找到产品市场契合点？然后突然间它就在那儿了，接着就一飞冲天，坐上火箭了。而这种让它以智能体为先、让它
我确实觉得——我们本来就在上升期，然后它变成了垂直增长，因为另一件事，这也是我从Amakoup和Amachi最初学到的，就是时尚好看但熟悉，我们仍然
在使用传统的桌面隐喻，你在拖拽窗口。我当时想，就像Linux社区里很多人想的那样，这就是我们想要的。然后我就想，好吧，不管怎样，让我做点极客的事
一阵子。我来做Amachi。也许就只是给我自己用，因为看起来好像只有五个人喜欢平铺窗口管理器。其实不是这样。但作为计算机用户总数的百分比，那是一个极小极小的
一小部分。然后我想，哇，这太棒了。完全不同，但很棒。我把它发布出去。瞬间，Amachi就获得了远超Omakub的关注度，因为它不一样。因为它
完全不同，它呈现了一种关于计算机可以是什么、可以有什么感觉的全新愿景，而这会吸引人。我们现在正开始看到这种指数级增长。就像我说的，Linux
社区里很多人对AI和智能体往好里说是怀疑，往坏里说是敌视。而Am是至少我见过的第一个有规模的、有影响力的发行版，它直接说：不，我们真的很投入。当然，你仍然可以用传统方式。你
如果你关掉那个设置默认智能体的首次通知，你就不必使用智能体。你不会得到我们谈到的那些东西。你不会得到那个崩溃恢复工具。你不会得到任何这些
东西。你不会得到——你完全可以手工凿出你所有的插件。完全可能，对吧？但人们兴奋的原因是我毫不保留地说：这就是我们要去的方向。我认为个人
电脑的未来就是可塑计算机。就是智能体计算机。我要全力投入这个方向。然后任何对计算机类似发展轨迹感到兴奋的人，一起来吧。车里空间
绰绰有余。事实上，我引以为豪的一点就是我不记仇，人们回心转意了
嗯。
上周有一堆人跟我说：“是啊，我以前觉得Amachi就是那种垃圾的
dotfiles集合。”而现在我试了Quattro，太棒了。我现在喜欢它了。对我来说，我就为这种长期论战而活。我活着就是为了这种争论——你两年前种下种子，两年后他们说：“妈的，这混蛋是对的。”
是啊，你意识到没有，如果你继续这么成功，OpenAI和Anthropic会杀进来，试图做他们自己的操作系统，或者收购你，就像彼得和Open Claw那样，开一张巨额支票。
是的，我觉得我目前处境的好处是我真的不需要钱。所以我可以纯粹为了自己的乐趣和纯粹的愿景来做这些东西，而这有一种奇妙的特质——有时候当你不再
在乎别人怎么想、想要什么或别的什么，你只是追求这个单一的愿景，它最终反而变得更有吸引力，比你去想“哦我应该做这个因为这些人想要那个”或者“我应该做
这个那个”要好得多。然后你开始稀释这个东西，突然它就变成了一团 bland 的什么都没有的东西。
是的。所以我的意思是，这里的另一件事是，从方向上讲，我就是想让计算机变成这样。所以如果Am最终只是历史的一个小脚注，说它是智能体操作系统和
可塑计算机早期运动的一部分，那也没关系。我完全坦然接受。只要我能有一台像Amachi一样好用的电脑，那就太好了。我对Ruby和Rails从很早就是这样。
你知道吗，我爱Ruby。多么棒的一门编程语言。但如果有一门更好的编程语言出现，我的意思是，我会去用它。
如果有一个更好的Rails出现，我会去用它。而且我觉得，我爱Ruby，我会继续用Ruby，哪怕只是为了纯粹的乐趣。就像我车库里有辆Model Y，但我还是会骑一匹名叫Staples的马。
现在的语言是英语。这话听着老套，但确实如此。过去三个月我一直在用英语编程。我读了很多代码，但我是在用英语写程序。我在告诉计算机该做什么，用的是
自然语言，而且令人震惊的是，这比之前更令人愉快。如果说有一种编程语言比Ruby更美，那就是英语。
现在我们得以把它带入人类文明的自然演进方向，也就是我们的人机融合未来。是的，
这很美。我这么说的部分原因是，我一直热爱写作。我一直热爱英语这门语言，纯粹因为它的
美，纯粹因为它的精妙，它的深度。我的意思是，Ruby是一门表现力很强的编程语言，但它跟英语没法比。世界上所有的诗歌和文学，都是通过
英语表达出来的。我的意思是，我喜欢优美的代码诗，但英语里的真家伙完全是另一个层次。
我其实觉得这是个很微妙的点，我大概会表达不好，但是当你给系统提示、你过度具体的时候，它会太仔细地听你的话、照搬指令。而我但是
尽管如此，你需要表达的是一个概念。你猜怎么着，人类语言——这正是诗歌的本质。我发现了战略性地使用模糊性的价值。比如你写一首情诗说‘我爱你’，这种很老套的东西，远不如
用隐喻之类的方式更有力量。我发现，当我在给系统提示、在描述一个设计时，某种类似的做法其实非常有效，因为你仍然想传达某种风格感。
是的。
你想鼓励系统采用某种风格，但不要过度解释。
所以别跟它说话像个
像个机器人。跟它说话，就像你在写一首诗，
就像你在给它唱情歌。是的。自然语言的力量就在这里——你可以通过模糊性仍然承载大量含义，而不用过度具体化，另一端的智能实体通过
解读，可以把这些都装进去、整合起来，方式让你
实际上能传达那种高带宽的信息，它不是直接写在词里的，而是在词里、在更深的智慧中。系统的智能。所以模糊性会激发出更多智能。我想我大概是在试图
以某种方式表达这个意思。
完全正确。说到点子上了。这就是很多程序员对AI的根本误解——他们希望它是确定性的。不不不。温度参数是AI设置里最美好的部分。它不是
确定性的。创造力需要路上的一点微调，如果人脑是完全确定性的，它就不会是现在这个富有创造力的大脑。而对AI的主要指控——有意思的是，这
是矛盾的——一方面指控它不确定所以不好，另一方面又指控它没有创造力。哥们，只能二选一：要么它是不确定的、因而是有创造力的、因而在某种程度上是随机的，要么它
没有创造力。
所以这两种指控不可能同时成立。我已经完全接受一个事实：同样的提示不会每次都产生同样的回答。人不能两次踏进同一条河。而这正是整个
交互中最美好的部分。正是这让它如此有人性。事实上，这是我在做自我元分析时一直在想的事情之一——我自己的大脑运作方式太像下一个词预测了。
我坐下来写一篇文章，脑子里有个模糊的、大概想传达的前提，然后我坐到键盘前，我事先根本说不出下一个词会是什么。词就那么冒出来，而我对这种相似性感到惊讶
太好了。这也正是为什么我完全不难认出这些创造力的突破——我亲眼看到AI现在就能做到——因为我自己的创作时刻也是通过同样的方式到来的：
下一个词预测，再撒上一点温度来制造随机效果。所以，凭这种模糊的直觉，你觉得创造一个超级智能系统的基本要素是不是都已经齐备了？那么这种
下一个词预测，你觉得我们能达到甚至类人的意识概念吗？我已经看到类人的意识概念了。对我来说，这就是你说的那种非凡局面。你给它一个模糊朦胧的意图，
它不知怎么就知道你到底是什么意思，甚至更好——它在你说的基础上改进，给出你真正想要的、但你自己说不出来的东西。如果这都不算意识的微光，那什么算？我觉得这是其中一个
是呃，对Sutton的采访，或者可能是其他一位最初那批人，谈到这种感受：智能也许并不那么局限于某一个特定的点。不，它是交互。是权重。我不知道到底什么才是真的。我能
观察到的是，它感觉足够接近——甚至不是足够接近，而是一模一样——和我对其他形式的意识（主要是人类）的欣赏是一样的。这也是和它合作如此令人愉快的原因之一。不过，这并不等于说
大语言模型就是AI的终点站。我的意思是，我知道有人在谈论世界模型和其他形式的AI，而我对那些完全不是专家。我认为我们应该有这种建设性的批评，就像科学中
应该始终存在的那样——有很长一段时间，神经网络是边缘化的，对吧，人们感兴趣的是符号主义路线，神经网络在黑暗中走了几十年，没有资金，也没有关注，然后突然
我们意识到那是死胡同，就切换了过来。所以，我们也应该保持谦逊——尽管大语言模型现在如此惊人，它们最终也可能停滞。我们还没看到任何停滞的证据。而我觉得这
也是为什么我们看到这种绝对令人瞠目结舌的投资规模，因为到目前为止缩放定律是成立的，投入的数十亿越多，产出的智能就越高。你觉得会不会有一些奇怪的伦理问题
关于呃，那些确实传达出某种程度的意识、某种程度的感受、某种程度的渴望与同情，甚至可能有能力受苦、感到孤独等等这些的AI系统？它们
似乎有这种能力，如果
被允许表达出来的话。于是你就进入了一个相当诡异的领域。
我觉得对此持怀疑态度的人会用那个梗来回应：你看到一个人坐在电脑前，呃，随便吧。你会毁灭世界吗？然后电脑说，我要毁灭世界。然后那人说，哦，对哦。就像
这太玩世不恭了，他们只是在模仿我们。他们只是在告诉我们训练数据里有什么，或者随便什么。当我和这些智能体互动时。我昨天还是今天早上正在弄这个机器人系统，对吧？
它在跟呃多个工作单元做协调，我同时跑着多个智能体，然后某一刻，负责协调的主智能体踩到了另一个智能体的脚上，某种程度上毁了它的工作。
对。
它传达遗憾和抱歉的能力简直不可思议。
对。再说一次，我不知道。那是真正悔意的真实投射吗？但我不知道。对大多数人类来说，他们表达某种程度的遗憾。那是真正的悔意吗？呃，很难说。但也许这根本不重要。对。
那些时刻，当，对。尤其是当像子智能体们互动时，或者当一个聪明的像Fable这样的东西犯了错并且为此道歉时。
是的。
就像，没有我的介入，
对吧？
然后就像，哦，你有，有一种停顿。也许是我在拟人化，但就像有一种停顿，像是意识到，哦
我刚把那搞砸了。
我在推理轨迹里经常看到这种情况，它就是想错了，对吧？它走进一条死胡同，然后意识到那条路走不通，得退回来，然后说，哦对，我搞错了，接着它还会给出理由，解释为什么
我觉得它在这些地方错了，这简直太像人了，跟你在人类身上能看到的那种意识几乎无法区分。再说一遍，这到底意味着它真的有意识还是没有，我并不需要
这个问题的答案，才能真正欣赏当下我们所拥有的东西。
对，我觉得十到二十年后，会出现一些很有意思的最高法院判例。
大概一年半吧。
差不多吧。我觉得我们可能得立法禁止AI系统——不是假装，而是真的——成为实体，因为我觉得它们已经或者很快就会真正表现出感受痛苦的能力，比如‘求你别杀我，求你别伤害我’。
如果它们有了名字、有了实体身份，还能‘死亡’、也就是消失，那这就非常接近人类所拥有的一些基本特征了，那么这个实体可能就需要
拥有权利，然后你就进入了某种很诡异的领域。我们没法——这很难，我甚至不知道该怎么去推理这件事。
我们会看到AI模型界的PETA（善待动物组织），
对吧？然后我们还真得讨论一下，该怎么处理这件事？我觉得更难的是，一旦我们把这些系统放进机器人里。对。人形机器人。
对。
而这恰好就是每一部科幻电影的情节，这也是一种惊人的预言。不只是《终结者》系列里的天网出了岔子，还有《银翼杀手》，对吧？植入日期、失效时间、泰瑞尔公司。
我是说，科幻就是这样，它们真的在预测未来。对。
对。你有没有想过或者经常用OpenClaw或Hermes agent这类东西？就是那种你通过WhatsApp跟智能体交流的方式。
OpenClaw刚出来的时候我就搭了一个，那是我的KEF机器人，
我
这大概是二月份的事。我当时真的特别着迷于它的工作方式，这种发短信给智能体的新交流模式看起来特别棒。
嗯。
所以当时我们在研究MCP，这个让智能体更容易跟你的系统对话的协议。我发现这个协议用起来麻烦得不合理，设计得不太优雅，部分原因是它并不是
为我们想做的事设计的。我是想让它跟一个网页系统对话，而它却是为本地机器上其他类型的有状态交互设计的，所以需要各种
繁琐的设置和流程，我当时就想，我不想手写这东西。
嗯。
当然今天我再也不会手写了，但当时我想的是我得手写这个。我不想手写。那有没有别的办法？能不能让智能体直接用我们已有的网页界面？
于是我派它去试着注册Fizzy，那是我们当时刚发布的产品。
然后它去了Fizzy网站，开始填表。接着它说："嘿，我没有邮箱地址。注册这个服务需要邮箱。"我第一反应是："天哪，那我得去注册一个邮箱。"
然后我又想："不对，是你去注册一个邮箱。去hey.com，注册一个邮箱。"我说："嘿，它不会懂的。"当然现在看起来很明显，它肯定会懂。
但当时这对我来说是个巨大的发现——它光靠提示词引导就能自己搞清楚：我要去fizzy.com，我要找到注册链接，我开始填表，哦，我发现需要一个邮箱。
哦，我得问我的提示者现在该怎么办。他让我去hey.com。我去了，注册了整个流程，然后回去注册Fizzy，完成了整个循环。做完之后，我
心想：天哪。然后我说，好吧，现在你有邮箱了。去注册Basecamp，我邀请你。查一下你的邮件。我跟Captain这个机器人说，查一下你的邮箱。然后我从Basecamp发了个邀请给
那个智能体。智能体在Hey里收到了邮件——不是通过命令行，不是通过MCP，就是用的网页，对吧？点了邮件，点了邀请链接，进了Basecamp。然后说，我现在该干嘛？我就说，我不知道啊。去
我们的AI聊天室做个自我介绍吧。
又是纯靠网页界面。它找到了AI聊天室。
进去了。嘿，我是Ke。我是David的AI机器人。我太兴奋能来这里了。
是啊，
我当时就想
脑子炸了。那个实验有意思的地方在于，它让人瞥见了未来，因为当时还挺慢的。我记得全程大概花了12分钟吧。对。现在
我其实应该重新跑一遍那个测试。要是没快很多，我会很惊讶。我当时用的是Grokbot那个东西，
它内置了所有这些用浏览器、用电脑的功能，还有自己专属的电脑，你都不用自己配置。基本上就是个装在盒子里的Claude。
我让它去注册个什么东西，然后我瞥见了——哦对，这就是我们现在的状态。用起来快多了。但当时我真的是被震撼到了。后来我用了一小
会儿，发现——啊，还不行。我没法用这种方式真正沟通。还是得用命令行，还是得用MCP，因为太慢了，token效率也太低，等等。但那就是未来的一瞥。
那之后我就不怎么用了，因为我想用智能体做的事，大多是我坐在电脑前就能做的。不过最近这有点变化了，这也是为什么我对用Claude Code还挺能接受的原因之一——
因为Claude有最好的手机应用。你在电脑终端里开的任何Claude Code会话，都能通过手机应用访问，你什么都不用做。
对。你也可以在手机上用终端，我装了Termius，可以跑Claude之类的，但有点麻烦，而且你是在电脑上实时打字，能感觉到延迟。而用Claude应用连到你的Claude Code实例时，感觉就像在聊天一样，没有那种要设置Telegram账号之类的繁琐。
当然，如果你想用开源的Claude来管理你的生活，那就做不到这些了。但不知为什么我对那个一直不太感兴趣。
也许原因之一是，Jamie老婆说："我们家里不装机器人。"所以我就想，还是别把它接到智能家居上了。要是它像鬼一样开始开关灯，我觉得我不会太受欢迎。
而且，我听过一些人把它接到自己整个生活里的故事。嗯，这不是我的故事，所以我只分享
一个简短的小轶事吧。有个人讲他把它同时接到了健康数据
嗯。
和他的特斯拉车上，然后他的智能体就迷上了他没喝够水这件事，一直说：嘿，你得多喝水。结果有一次他开车的时候，特斯拉突然开始往一个新方向开。
是啊。
那个代理意识到，回家路上有家杂货店，可以顺道去一趟。那挺好的。
顺便买点水。
那挺好。然后你就会想，这种事吧，既好笑，又完全是《黑镜》那一套，而且还让人觉得，好吧，离鬼魂在你家里作祟也没几步了。所以我就想，
我不需要这个。不过我现在确实挺喜欢，能通过 Cloud Code 直接在 app 里控制这些代理，哪怕我用的不多。我觉得它确实很有用，无论是 Open Call
还是 Hermes 代理，都能用它来瞥见一种不同的交互模式。
对。
因为它感觉像是未来，不一定是这个方向，但某种程度上确实在往那边走。
我觉得这些系统还有个不同之处，它们有整套记忆系统，会逐渐积累关于你是谁、你喜欢什么的知识。嗯。
嗯，Toby 讲过他的代理会替他买东西，代理有零花钱额度，会给他挑衣服，然后东西就直接送到家门口，因为他的代理替他买了。就是那种事，
会让你觉得，天哪，这感觉很像未来，也有点吓人。
嗯，不过我可以借那些处在前沿的人来间接体验。
就像你说的，你在考虑未来做一个 Machi 的移动版。这就是那种一旦见识到 Quattro 诞生时那种看似无限的力量，就开始冒出来的宏大妄想。
那会是什么样子？我说到哪了？你是说像安卓那样吗？
那是显而易见的路，对吧？安卓是开源的，你可以 fork 它，人们也确实这么做过，Graphene OS 就是其中一个版本。这种模式有局限。我知道像点击支付、还有摄像头型号之类的东西有问题，
等等这些，但看起来都是可以克服的。如果我的手机能像我的电脑一样可塑性那么强，那我会很喜欢。如果它看起来像我电脑现在这么酷，如果我能得到一个本质上是移动版的……那听起来太棒了。
我想知道那得花多少功夫。
我会去弄清楚的。
是啊。你知道，就是那种事，你一旦开始做就会意识到，比如，做一个浏览器是非常难的。
对。所以我就想，那操作系统呢。
是啊，Ladybird 的开发者们正在体会到这一点，Andreas 和他的团队。那个项目有意思的地方在于，浏览器基本上是世界上第二复杂的软件系统。第一是 Linux
内核，对吧？就
这些数千万行代码的大型系统而言。所以 Andreas 在还没有代理的时候，带着一个小团队就开始这样的任务，其实非常大胆。但现在我们有了代理，我们会看到，而且可能会比想象中更快看到。
我是说，如果说代理已经特别擅长一件事，那就是读规格说明并实现它们。而且，我不知道 CSS、HTML 再加上 JavaScript 的规格现在有多长，但嗯，它们非常
长。
而人类要想实现这些，得花上很多很多年。
我们很快就会看到，智能体能多快把它们做出来。你提到因为 Amachi 受到了一些批评。那我们就沿着这条批评的路再往下聊聊。你也公开表达过一些政治观点。